what's she like in private is she very
funny really very funny wants to crack a
joke and craft a joke about me turns out
queen elizabeth has no problem poking
fun at james bond i'm very quite
embarrassed now and
can't look you in the face daniel craig
who recently made his last movie as the
handsome spy stopped by the late show
with stephen colbert on wednesday and
opened up about meeting her majesty
while filming a sketch for the opening
ceremony of the 2012 london summer
olympics
yeah the actor recalled filming that
scene which involved james bond picking
up the queen at buckingham palace flying
to millennium stadium and in true
double-07 fashion jumping out of the
helicopter and parachuting into the
crowd
and behind the scenes the queen was
teasing daniel yeah she she just she
said we were we're having our
photographs taken and she just went oh
no he's the one that doesn't smile
fair enough that's nice yeah nice crack
there you go in addition to getting some
playful shade from the royal daniel got
to spend some time with her corgis who
were also featured in the sketch i was
rolling around on the floor with them
most of the time yeah that's good i mean
they're just there and there's a i think
they have their own footmen i mean like
i wouldn't be surprised i'm not
surprised about it but someone was just
looking after after them and i just yeah
they're very friendly of course back in
october after over a decade of
portraying the iconic role daniel took
his final bow with the fifth and final
installment of his run as bond in no
time to die this is gonna be my last one
someone else should have a go the past
isn't dead i'm very proud of what we've
done i'm so lucky to have been sort of
had this this opportunity for the past
16 years it was a slog it's gone like
that it's just it's you know i i'm i
remember being announced as james bond
like it was yesterday leading up to his
final bond films premiere the action
star reflected as his time as a secret
agent during a sit-down with e.t i've
changed
immeasurably since i began this in my
professional life and in my personal
life clearly it's given me
a confidence that i didn't have when i
started off this confidence to sort of
try and make the best
of what you have and make the best
movies we can and that's all i ever ever
wanted out of this and as his time as
bond came to an end his no time to die
co-stars couldn't help but gush to et
over his epic run as the legendary
character i've just really enjoyed
watching him um
take on the responsibility of this thing
and kind of grow into it and you know
he's really he's just rocked it it's
emotional because it is daniel's last
film and he gave so much you know for
this character he gave 15 years of his
life i'm a huge fan of daniels wanted
this to be a really special send-off for
him and i think we accomplished that
[Music]